for more on this let's bring in texas
lieutenant governor dan patrick it's
been quite a week oh and it's only
wednesday uh the mexican president
andres manuel lopez obrador he also
blamed lack of control at the u.s border
for death saying that it happens because
there is trafficking of people and a
lack of control in this case at the
mexican-us border but also in the u.s
interior
i would imagine that you agree with that
well totally agree dana and when i hear
john pierre make that statement that the
border is closed i can't say anything
other than this that's just a flat out
lie
she's lying to the american people
this administration biden still hasn't
been to the border kamala harris it was
a joke trip a year ago once you went to
el paso they have not seen it for
themselves but you know they're getting
reports from border patrol
they know it's wide open you know we we
set a record last month 239 000 there's
another 50 or 60 000 got aways people we
see we can't catch and then of course
they're all the people that cross that
we don't see i've been saying dana for
years of my speeches people should not
have to come to america in the back of
an 18 wheeler and die i've been saying
that forever
and this is where we are this is an
administration that is a culture of
death
every policy that they have
results in death whether it's soldiers
in afghanistan whether it's
people on the street innocent victims of
criminals or running a muck on our
streets whether it's this 51 hapless
souls who died a terrible death these
poor people that died in the back of
that truck or whether it's now a plan by
the bide administration to set up
abortion camps so that they can take
more babies lives everything this
administration touches results in death
and these 51 people who died are on
their hands and john pierre
it is
just unbelievable she will look america
in the eye and say the border is secure
that is just a joke it's laughable and
in this case it cost people their lives
all right sticking on the southern
border then the wall street journal
editorial board headline today said that
when u.s immigration policy kills
migrants trapped in a tractor trailer
died in the soaring heat we saw those
temperatures just a moment ago from
janice dean and jillian
they went on to say that the biden
administration has the duty to fix this
so migrants don't have to play roulette
with their lives but as with so many
other issues this white house seems
trapped by the demands of the political
left to do little or nothing at the
border more human tragedies are
inevitable and i certainly don't speak
for jean-pierre but i'm trying to watch
what other democrats are saying as
they're asked about this and one of the
things i'll say is that well it's closed
meaning that there's not enough legal
pathways for immigrants so that's why
this is happening
and
it feels disingenuous even as i'm saying
that i'm trying to explain it on their
behalf which is really not my job but
just to try to provide their point of
view and i see them going down this path
but the people of texas arizona new
mexico and the southern californians are
they going to buy that
well no we're not buying it in texas
i'll be down i know the governor's down
there today i'll be down at several
parts of the border tomorrow and dana
here's what the average american who
really doesn't have to follow it closely
day to day let their eyes tell them what
is the truth
closed means or secure means no one's
coming in it's closed we're closed can't
come in anymore the doors are shut and
we had and we're going to break another
record this month
and all the drugs that are coming in on
top of this all the criminals that are
coming on top of this this is
this is
a selling out of america
these people are are they come across
this border trust me there are many who
die just in the in the vast wasteland of
texas in this hot sun when they're
dropped off uh by by different smugglers
in the middle of nowhere with no water
uh plus the people have drowned in the
river and the president does he have no
conscience
does he never hold himself accountable
for anything all the people are dying of
fentanyl in this country that he's also
allowed in and again it's a culture of
death that he doesn't seem to care about
whether it's a baby in the womb or
people in the trailer has he one time
dana since this happened
has he had any empathy and any concern
any caring in a true passionate way
about these people who are dying all
across america whether again it's just
so forth or across the border and also
for the people who work for him the
border patrol who um griff said there
are 124 people who have died uh but that
we didn't put up the number that they've
saved because there's been a lot of
interventions in order to help protect
them um you're going to stick around and
be available next hour just in case we
get the supreme court ruling about the
remain in mexico policy so stay stay
close don't go out too far we'll be back
at that thank you big decision okay big
decision indeed thank you so much